ça fait rien à voir avec mes repères que
j'avais avant centre du travail c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué jordan a 28 ans
au chômage depuis plusieurs mois et son
retour sur la région parisienne il
espère décrocher un emploi dans la
menuiserie et pour cela ils participent
à l'opération coup de pouce pour un
emploi
bilan de l'après midi trois entretiens
directs avec des employeurs et déjà une
promesse d'embauché
en fait on sélectionne ce qu'on a envie
par rapport à ce que nous propose on
voit ce que nous proposons c'est tout de
suite ça va aller ça va pas aller et
puis ça nous dépendons entre guillemets
notre goût gras quoi on va proposer un
travail dans un secteur maintenance à
moi d'y réfléchir c'est à moi de
rencontrer ces personnes là pour voir le
salaire qu'on peut si on me le propose
signaux intéressants pour moi comme
jordan ils étaient près de 80 jeunes
diplômés ou non à participer à cet après
midi rencontre une vingtaine
d'entreprises étaient présentes dans des
secteurs variés manutention aide à la
personne ressource humaine ou encore
transport principal avantage pour les
entreprises révéler des talents parfois
cachés dans un cv bien sûr ça permet de
faire de franchir cette barrière du cv
puisque le premier contact vous permet
de déceler une motivation et une envie
et une orientation professionnelle qui
n'est pas toujours facile à traduire
dans un cv parfois les candidats ne
mentionne pas non plus toute leur
expérience dans un celi l'opération coup
de pouce pour un emploi permet en
moyenne l'embauché d'une quinzaine de
candidats par après midi